cuz you said you left Islam right so am
I correct yeah to myself I I haven't
told family or anything Allah will never
throw you in Hell Fire you know why CU
Allah says in the Quran what will I get
out of punishing you come back because I
think I left the folds of Islam like 5
10 years ago I want to go back to you
know I want to start you know going to
the mosque don't five times a day and
you're a cafer no who told you this who
told you this that that one guy we love
you we want the best for you and don't
let anybody make you feel like you're a
cfir or you're a maaf you are not you
want to take a sh with me um take take a
sh do you want to speak with confidence
like these amazing personalities every
single one of these amazing speakers
have taken the same program with brother
Muhammad Arad Muhammad Arad has helped
develop all of us it's extremely
beneficial to do this course definitely
recommend this course
to access the free lifechanging training
now so yes brother um are you ready
let's talk in so what's what's the
reason you left Islam I I left Islam
because I didn't like the rulings of it
because I didn't see anywhere in the
Quran where it said you have to pray
like five times a day it's just like I
didn't take that seriously you know so I
stopped praying and stuff and my whole
family they don't pray either so you
know I was just I was just you know like
chilling and all and just being agnostic
you know it's believe telling people I
believe in God that's it you know I
don't know anything about nothing you
know okay that's fine let's talk about
that but can we see you if you don't
mind me can we see you please yeah yeah
one second one
second and where are you calling from by
the way which country uh I'm in us oh
you in the US okay yeah let's
talk went outside like in the backyard
because I want to know that's fine
that's fine no problem okay we can see
him now yeah okay right let's talk to so
how are
do am I good yeah you're good you're
good maybe just go sit somewhere go sit
somewhere yeah yeah yeah I like your I
like your Shades oh yeah thank you
you're looking cool man you you look
like a cool guy you got the Quran yeah
okay so how old are you I'm
19 you're 19 okay M so you're young okay
so um in a nutshell look this is what I
say to you yeah okay so you said that
what was the main reason you left Islam
what's the main main reason the main
main reason I just um you know I I like
to believe in things that are like
empirically like with evidence I don't
like to believe in things that don't
have empirical evidence and things that
you know like that and stuff like that
you know sunas and
Hadith okay that's F all beliefs and
rituals and
culture what's your name I
put I I don't want people to know my
real name but it's to me okay okay okay
no it's fine what can I call you can I
just give me a name that I can call you
uh yeah yeah you can you can call me
tamim it's okay what's that tamim yeah
you can call me tamim Tam Tam tamim yeah
yeah yeah okay tamim so you you said
that uh obviously before I start want to
praise Allah and I ask Allah to make
this a fruitful discussion and it means
that you get closer to Allah in in
Ramadan and that you become a Muslim and
that you fast Ramadan with us in you are
our brother fasting I just don't do
religiously I I still
do and I still I don't pray five times
okay so so but because you said you left
Islam it's um in order for those actions
to be accepted obviously you have to be
a Muslim so we want you to come back to
Islam that you do those actions as a
Muslim if I'm not mistaken because you
said you left Islam right so am I
correct well I mean yeah to myself I I
haven't told family or anything like
people because I have some um other
families who are like stri in Islam then
I have my own family who doesn't do
Islam so the family that takes Islam
like more strictly like I didn't tell
them you know I still go pray with them
and all that but I don't you know take
it seriously you I just do it cuz
everyone else is doing I don't want to
like okay that's fine so so
so yeah internally you don't believe
anymore but externally you just want to
be in Union with your family correct
basically basically okay so you talked
about empiricism let's talk about
empiricism yeah so uh you said that you
only believe in stuff that you
empirically verify so this is you know
obviously your five senses to see touch
feel uh taste and he here um so
obviously um I would say to you look do
you believe uh that love exists no you
don't believe love exists no I mean I I
believe like people you know taking care
of you doing like your kns and stuff
yeah but like love itself is just like I
don't think that's a real thing you know
so you don't believe okay good okay
that's fine no problem do you believe uh
you have a conscious conscious yeah yeah
okay so I I want to obviously be a
believer
that you have conscious I want to I'm
I'm going to have the position that I'm
in doubt I'm a I'm a disbeliever in your
conscious so I don't believe you have
conscious so can you empirically prove
to me that you have a conscious so I can
believe that now because like I've got
the camera now I can look at you I can
see you can you just quickly show me
your Consciousness so I can just verify
and be like you know what you have the
only way I could verify is like if I
like like hit myself and it hurts or
something like that but I would have
feel that but I would I would that to
you though I I I don't want you to hit
yourself but I wouldn't feel that you
hit yourself that wouldn't prove
anything to me you exactly so you get it
it's like I exist therefore I am yeah
okay so what I'm saying is this can you
show me allow me to taste touch feel or
hear you're conscious could you do that
is it possible is it is it possible to
prove
that um I don't think it's I don't think
it's like possible to like prove it like
you know other people they they say they
they taste something and hear and all
that but I don't think no you can't
prove those those things I don't think
so okay good so basically then what that
means is that empirical evidence that
you want for God's existence it's you
can't do that for yourself in the sense
where you can't even prove your own
existence by showing me your
Consciousness yeah that you have a
conscious so what I'm saying is if
that's the case then how can we have
that a yard stick to prove God exists
because we we believe God exists because
of the things we see yes that we see
like for example my eyes I can see my
eyes my hand my nails my organs my
kidney my liver my heart I know they
exist and they have a function it's like
a dark matter dark matter you cannot
touch F taste here or or or feel but we
know it exists because we see the
remnance and the side we the effects of
it so what I'm saying is brother is to
deny that God exists because you cannot
see him or you want to see him it
doesn't work because there's so many I I
don't think I don't think because I know
there's like people who are blind and
stuff you know they obviously can't
won't be able to see God
SOA that not only that for example how
could you explain to a blind person
color now just because he doesn't see
does it mean color doesn't
exist I mean you could tell them that
but to them it won't how how would you
okay how could you explain the red color
to a blind person red color to blind
person I just say it's something bright
cuz blind people you know they're seeing
like what we see behind our head we
can't see right that's basically that's
fine okay so you telling me something
bright but what about blue and red and
green and purple and orange are are you
gonna say they're all bright he needs to
know what's the disting what's the
difference between a red color and a
blue color and a purple color and a pink
color if you say it's bright what does
bright mean so like red color like
nothing basically like to the to the
blind person you know so a red color you
can never ever explain the red concept
the red color the blue color to a blind
person but this doesn't mean it doesn't
so therefore you need to understand that
you can't say God doesn't exist because
I don't see him empirically would you
say that is fair that is fair I just I
do know like there you know God is just
like like a theory when you think about
it because it's just us being scared of
something watching over Humanity you
know but really
anyone I wouldn't say that it's a theory
it's a real fact there are people who
make fake gods and like Boogeyman and
stuff like that but there is the one
true God for example uh you know for
example that the Universe exists did
where did the universe come
from the universe come from the universe
came from nothing because everything
from nothing but God itself right is
always exist before nothing so okay one
second it's different how can something
come from nothing how can something come
from nothing
yeah how can something come from nothing
it can come from nothing just like how
we say God comes from nothing without
explanation it's the same we we never
said God came we never said God have a
beginning or God came from nothing or
God that defines that God came from
nothing if you say God is Not beginning
that mean no because because if we say
God has no beginning or end that means
there was never there was never a
nothingness well God itself there never
was nothing like the existence of God
never been but but
nothing God has always been
there no we say we say Allah has always
been there because Allah is a necess
being the creation the universe the
universe began to exist do you accept
that the Universe began to
exist me the universe began to exist I
mean yeah I'm in it right now yeah that
I do I agree with that okay so if the
universe began to exist then it cannot
come from nothing because at one point
it began to exist that's what I'm saying
just God by itself before there's
universe and all that it was just God
was okay okay so God gave rise to the
universe do you accept that God gave
rise to the universe um
oh yeah yeah I mean I God I already read
like the Quran I know how like it made
all that the heaven and stuff I know
that part I'm just I'm just I'm just
confused how why was God always there is
like a big question that's unanswerable
you okay so so we say we say that God
was has to always be there because the
one who created the universe has to be
ever living it's a have you heard of
necessary being it is necessary for God
to exist because otherwise we would not
be here the universe won't be here
everything that we have in our system in
in in the earth it's laws it all has
laws and boundaries yes so there is
order if there is order there has to be
an order Setter so what we're seeing is
that if your doubt is about Allah's
existence I don't know if it is I'm I'm
still a little bit confused um you
believe in God
correct yeah just like agnostically you
know I don't believe in doing any of the
rituals cultures that's fine that's fine
that's F that's fine the the five I
don't do that that's fine let's leave
Islam for a second now you do believe
that
exists yeah yeah yeah you go to think
before like the quarks you know the
smallest thing in Universe before the
quarks when there was nothing it was
only God so I mean that that's the only
way it makes sense for me I can't think
of nothing else smaller than quirks you
know okay good good okay yeah God exists
yeah God is the one that made those you
know to the atomic level Etc if God
exists your problem is with religion not
with God yeah I just don't like doing
religion because I mean when you think
about it right I don't know where in the
Quran it says this or where which Hadith
but basically everything is
predetermined by God right so God
already has put my place whether or not
I'm going to end up in heaven or hell
wherever I go that's already
predetermined so why should you do all
the you know stuff that God tells us to
do in the Quran and all that okay okay
good all right good okay so the question
is you're asking the question of yeah
now before I do that brother just so I
know brother tamim I'm just going to do
a um just because we're doing a
fundraiser and this is going to be a
long discussion I'm just going to just
remind the people about donating okay
give me just just 30 seconds yeah so
guys who are watching how many people
watching brother tamim do you know how
to pray Salah by the
way uh I I know like a little bit I just
um okay I will in good I'm gonna in
myself if you come back to Islam I'm
gonna teach you how to pray Salah myself
I'm gonna dedicate me on zoom we're
going to go and do it for free I'm going
to send you this guided prayer mat but
let's get back to our conversation in
yeah so brother tamim may Allah bless
him in he looks like James Bond he's
looking yes he's looking
extra dangerous as you can see yeah so
brother now let's go to the issue of so
the is the following so basically it's
that if Allah knows where I'm going then
how is it my fault
correct yep yep okay so what we say is
this look I was in your situation about
13 years ago I came to Islam 11 years
ago and before that I was looking into
okay I always believed in God but I
didn't believe in religion I thought it
just man-made if God knows everything
Etc what you need to understand is in
Islam we believe in compatibilism which
means the following we say God knows
everything and he's predetermined
everything and he's created our action
but this doesn't mean we don't have free
will now how they work together we don't
know but let me give you an example that
would maybe make sense to you okay so
tell me I'm G to give you as an example
okay now tamim let's suppose you believe
that you are going Hellfire so in your
head you know what I'm gonna go Hell
Fire so I'm not going to um I'm not I'm
I'm I'm I'm I think I'm going Hell Fire
fire yeah but even though you think
you're going Hellfire cuz you're like
Allah knows everything and Allah has
written I'm going Hellfire you still
have a bit of Hope and say you know what
I still going to I'm still going to pray
my Salah I'm still going to worship
Allah I'm still going to give him zaka
I'm still going to fast in Ramadan I'm
still going to do whatever I need to do
and I'm going to stay away from major
sins is that clear yeah I want to do
that yeah so good so good tamim there's
tamim and let's say there's Ali tamim
believes he's going Hellfire but he
still does Good Deeds he still prays he
still fasts he still gives in zaka he
still gives in charity he still does all
these good deeds and then there's Ali
Ali thinks he's going to Paradise he's
like you know what I'm definitely going
Jenna Bro I'm good I'm saved I believe
Allah has written that I'm going Jenna
but he doesn't pray his Salah he doesn't
fast in Ramadan he doesn't pay his Zak
he always commits sins now there's Tam
and Ali yep do you understand both of
them well I mean I do sin though so I
mean I'm kind of an Ali no no that's
fine we can sin I'm talking about sins
here there yeah I'm giving you an
example so there's tamim who thinks he's
going Hell Fire but he does good deeds
and he obeys Allah and there's Ali who
thinks he's going Jenna but he does bad
Deeds now if they stand in front of
Allah on the day of judgment and tamim
comes and says oh Allah I I I I I know
you're sending me Hell Fire he thinks he
I know but he prayed
he fasted in Ramadan he gave in charity
he done good deeds do you think Allah
will send tamim to Hellfire or
Jenna um I would I would believe Jenna
because if we you know tried to go there
yeah good good perfect perfect you know
why it doesn't matter what tamim thinks
or where tamim thinks he's going where
he thinks going is irrelevant because
you know why because Allah says in the
Quran
now yeah those who believe Muslims and
the MS so Allah is saying that they will
enter Jenna so how could it be that if
Allah knows where we're going but then
he's Allah is telling us to do good
deeds the point is this if you do good
deeds bro if you pray Salah if you do
zaka if you fast in Ramadan why would
Allah send you Hellfire even if you
thought oh no but Allah knows everything
if he knows I'm going Hellfire the point
is this it's not where Allah knows where
you're going it's to see that are you
going to put the effort in okay because
at the end of the day if you put the
effort in Allah will never throw you in
Hellfire you know why because Allah says
in the Quran what what will I get out of
punishing you Allah is telling you why
would I why would I punish you Brothers
my dear brother tamim and understand
this yeah we only enter Jenna with the
mercy of Allah by the mercy of Allah we
enter Jenna that's the ultimate reason
why but if you come with good deeds my
young brother if you come praying if you
come with the Salah with the zakat and
the fasting and staying away from sins
as much as you can we're all human
beings and Allah doesn't want you to be
sinless by the way bro Allah is not
telling you to be an angel yeah okay the
Sinners do you know what who Jenna is
for Jenna is for the Sinners that's
repented all of us ENT Jenna do you
think we're sinless we are sinners
inshallah so what I'm saying is bro does
that answer your question does that make
sense for what I'm saying to you uh yeah
of course I'm just saying um I mean I
think I've done some major sins you know
since the unforg so no no no no no no no
bro bro listen to me listen to me no sin
that you commit is greater than Allah's
Mercy not any sin you commit I do not
care what it is if Unforgiven though so
that's saying no no no no if you die on
it you are you still alive I'm alive
right now right now oh are you dead am I
speaking to you in the dead are you are
you dead or you live alive right now are
you sure about that let me see let me
double check can you wait for the camera
waave about the
camera okay yeah okay yeah he's
definitely alive okay okay since you're
alive bro there is room for repentance
okay there's room for improving do you
get what I'm trying to say yeah so do
not ever diser the mercy of Allah subh
tala Allah subhana wa tala says there's
a if the son of Adam's sins were to
reach the mountains and the skies and I
will forgive every single one except
shik and that is if the one dies on shik
whatever sin you committed even if it's
sh major sin Allah will forgive you and
let me tell you something is there a
more of a beautiful place time to us for
repentance then in Ramadan do you know
this is the month Allah frees the neck
of thousands and millions of people from
the Hellfire do you know this I know
this I know I think the the Satan is
locked I think and there's only small
small exactly exactly so bro bro let me
tell you something it is in your hands
it might be that you may have been
destined to help or whatever you want to
call it but your action inshallah Allah
subhana wa tala can change that Dua Dua
can change that so what I'm saying is
this bro yeah you're in Ramadan bro let
me tell you something we can help answer
your questions what other doubts do you
have tell me talk to me and by the way
you have any other question I mean I
just want to know how I can um put
action because I I don't put action into
what I do because I do things I don't I
don't take it seriously like I told you
I just I pr it then it's week later
months later years later you know so I
haven't done it for say that again say
that again I say like I'm gonna you know
become good Muslim when I come us
because I came from Germany and I said
I'm in us you know I'm G see my cousins
and all that I'm gonna start praying
with them they're gonna teach me and all
that and it never happened you know I
barely know any Islam to this day okay
okay listen understand listen I will I
will help you learn how to pray Salah
and any other courses you want to carry
on further if I'm free I would if not we
will have someone dedicated to you to
help you teach how to pray Salah but let
me tell you something bro look we all
sin don't think sinning makes you a bad
Muslim and you're doomed this is not our
religion okay that's what Allah says in
the
[Music]
Quran
oh my servants who have transgressed
against themselves do not ever dispur
the mercy of your lord indeed Allah
subhana is the one who forgives all sins
bro listen to me do not ever ever despur
the M Allah subhana tala whatever sins
you've done Allah is telling you his
doors are always open for you so have a
new beginning it's Ramadan okay it's
Ramadan inshah it's a new beginning okay
so do that do you have any other
questions that you have doubts about
Islam anything that I could answer I
want know I can you know come come back
because I think I left the fs of Islam
like five 10 years ago I want to go back
to you know I want to start you know
going to the mosque and actually okay
stop stop fresh look look this Ramadan
is a ra Ramadan start fresh inshallah
bro okay start fresh do this year go
home today if you want look if if you
saying that you you did you didn't
blasphemy
before
you've done blasing me before I mean
probably like I don't know like you know
you worship idols and all that like you
know stuff on your phone probably I've
done it I'm not sure though what what
makes what makes you think you've F
you've left the F of Islam with like
blasphemy what makes you feel did you
bow down to an
idol I mean probably I no I didn't I
don't think I bow down to an idol it's
just I think I was like you know like
looking at like idols and stuff you know
stuff on Instagram and all that and I
just um you know forget about Allah and
I just like oh my God this this is like
a god but obviously it's not you know
things like that okay so so so there was
a moment where you looked at an idol and
thought that that is God I mean like a
god not like the God you know like a God
okay all right that may have did you did
you believe that in your heart like when
you look did you say it maybe like
what well no I I just like you know see
some people like like boxers and all
that like you know you see them like
knocking out people
or like Mike Tyson and all that back in
the day I'm like yeah that's like
basically what God could do you know but
obviously it's not but God understand
like understand you know again yeah it
can it is it is a dangerous statement
yeah so let's do this bro why don't you
just take a shahada again with us and
let's have a beginning is any other
questions you have is there any other
questions you have do do I have to do
like woodoo before I do it look it'll be
nice after you sh just take it's a new
beginning repent don't are you fasting
now me no
okay so what I would say is bro New
Beginning
do do sh with me start fasting Ramadan
tonight ask Allah and say oh Allah I
really want to change myself yeah I'm
doing a lot of sins Etc I've done things
that are wrong I've even maybe committed
sh knowingly unknowingly please I just
want your help this Ramadan call out to
Allah cry to him open your hands bro and
ask him ask him and say Allah please
guide me like please I need your help
this Ramadan bro Allah will help you
believe me W Allah will help you cuz I'm
a witness to this Allah subh has helped
me even certain things that I would do
you know Allah subhana has helped me and
aided me and I was just what 23 years
old when I came to Islam just four years
older than you so it's never too late
bro and I will help you inshallah I'm
going to send you you see one of these
prayer
mats you see
this oh yeah okay I'm gonna send you one
of this inshah go to the group chat
message me on Instagram I'm going to
send you one of these ones for free and
I'm going to book a Salah session in
with you and I'm going to teach you how
to pray Salah again but you're not in
the US though right you're not you're
not here right no I'm in UK London I
can't come here yeah I would love to I
would I mean if you was in London I
would come to you like but but listen
let's do this inshallah Tam so you want
to take a shahada with me um take take a
Shah again
yes I want to take a when I do when I'm
ready cuz I don't think I'm ready yet I
don't think I'm I'm I'mma go tonight
like you told me cry um and like you
know make do I don't think I'm gonna do
that I think I'm gonna go straight to
like my desires you know and go straight
okay listen list thoughts all the listen
happens every time I've done shahada in
theas Germany right then I came to us I
had to do shahada again because I didn't
pray for so many years and then I always
like keep leaving and so I don't want to
I don't want to disappoint you because
you know okay okay look bro you're not
nothing for me let's just make this
thing clear you're not doing nothing for
me you're doing this for yourself yeah
you're not you're not doing nothing for
me in the sense obviously it's good that
if I encourage you to good I'll get
reward but don't think like you're doing
anything for me bro you're not
disappoint I'm a nobody don't care about
my feelings or what I think about it
it's about Allah one thing I think
there's a big misconception is bro you I
think you think when you take your
shahada and you fall into a sin you feel
like okay I'm done you shouldn't feel
like that bro you can go back to desires
you can take your shahada now you can go
back to your sins
I'm saying that is your Muslims fall
into sins so don't think like you doing
that makes you something different bro I
sin do you understand I sin I go give
daah I go sin I commit sins do you get
what I'm trying to say so you need to
understand you committing sins doesn't
take you out the fold of Islam your
desires you're going to go back to okay
that doesn't make you a cafir you are a
Muslim that's sinning just like any
other Muslim that sins of course you
should try to stop stop it but don't
don't five times a day and you're a CAF
no who told you this who told you this
who told you this that that one guy um
you know he he said like like one of
those shaks he said
like listen listen listen listen whoever
it is please listen to me listen to me
bro listen to me I think you would
probably know him he's pretty popular
yeah I may know who you're talking about
listen to me bro listen that's not true
that's not true okay uh that's not true
that's somebody who
just if you don't like cuz before you go
I just want to say if you you know like
if you pray sometimes then you're a
hypocrite but if you don't pray at all
then you're cfers and me I don't think
I'm a hypocrite I think I'm straight to
being caffer that's why I was scared of
you know brother brother brother you're
not a hypocrite know you're a cafir I
know you have IM in your heart I know
you love Allah and his messenger I know
tamim if you didn't love Allah and his
messenger you would not come to this
life you would not take this time to
talk to me you love Allah and his
messenger bro okay exactly do you hear
me Tam listen to me bro don't let anyone
ever tell you that you're a maaf or a
cfir okay well I'm getting Goosebumps
yeah listen to me brother yeah you're
our brother we love you we want the best
for you and don't let anybody make you
feel like you're a cfir or you're a maaf
you are not okay I know you love Allah
and his messenger there was a companion
of the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him he used to drink alcohol in front of
the prophet he used to drink alcohol and
he was in the Battle of bad and yeah bro
you know what happened to him they they
were going to lash him they were going
to whip him as a punishment yeah and
guess what once I think it was one of
the companions they you know what they
said to him you know what they said to
him to me they said may Allah may Allah
curse you yeah and the prophet got so
angry he said don't say that to him even
though he's drinking he drinks alcohol
he's got habit of alcohol but he loves
Allah and his messenger just because you
commit a sin bro it doesn't make you a
cfir it doesn't make you a maaf he makes
you a Muslim who's a sinner and you only
can repent and get close to Allah do you
understand me so don't let anybody tamim
ever let you feel like you are a maafi
you're a c no you're not you are like a
Muslim like everybody else is and you
are trying your best to get to Jenna
okay I I haven't done for 10 years
that's it I Haven no problem you haven't
done it let me tell you something let me
tell you something I didn't pray for 23
years I was a non-muslim for 20 2 3
years I didn't pray bro for 23 years I
did all kinds of sins all kinds of sins
I used this body Allah gave me for so
much sins bro but Allah turns for the
repentant those who repent and change
their ways bro Allah will help them so
10 years I don't care today is the day
you're going to change in
okay I hope so I go back
straight
h
Huh you mentioned that you you're from
Germany no no not only that tamim so
many people are listening to your story
now live
people nine
nine
and brothers and sisters we are going to
help our te to learn how to pray Salah
so listen to me take your Shah with me
you become a Muslim I don't care what
sins you commit dirty now I'm not gonna
lie I feel dirty like
I listen to me listen to me tell before
this um what is it called nocturnal
mission is not allowed it's not you have
to do after I've read it about it so if
you do nocturnal Miss nocturnal mission
is not allowed what's that you have to
because it's you don't know what
nocturnal mission
is no what is that because it's not
allowed that's why I have to do before I
do anything no no what's not allowed one
second who's telling you this bro where
you this information if you're sleeping
if you're sleeping and you you um natur
Mission wake up like like
um no no actually listen brother brother
that's not true you can take your sh bro
there's mush who are Allah in the Quran
they unclean spiritually they take the
shahada yeah bro that's not ask people
about this they told me you can't have
that happen you have to no no bro I'm
telling bro listen to me listen to me
you can take your shahada and you can go
and do you can I'm telling you don't let
the Shayan trick you into this you can
I'm telling you you can if you wake up
that way the whole day is dirty until
you know no listen to me you can still
take your shahada bro trust me you just
go home and take a shower your shahada
is got you are spiritually cleansing
yourself that is also a a a form of it
but it's not that doesn't stop you
otherwise there might be people who had
w dreams maybe they committed Zena maybe
they worshiped an idol they coming to
take the shahada are we going to tell
them don't do it until no that's not
true bro take your shahada with me and
it's a new beginning okay yeah do you
want to repeat after me uh you want to
do English or you want to do um let's do
in Arabic first Arabic first right
yes do you know it if you know it say
it okay
again Allah Allah
Muhammad
muhamad I bear witness I bear witness
there is nothing worthy of worship
there's nothing worthy of worship except
Allah except Allah and Prophet Muhammad
and Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him be upon Him is his
final messenger his final messenger
welcome back Aki listen to me very
carefully yeah you are you are just like
us Allah subhana tala will wipe away all
your sins and I don't care if you go
back to those sins you are a Muslim even
if you commit sinso you're not a maafi
you're not a cfir because you don't pray
listen to me you are a Muslim that loves
Allah and his messenger anytime you get
doubt I want you to tell yourself I love
Allah and his messenger and I am
striving to get better simple as and
today go home do bro and inshallah start
your first fasting tomorrow take it easy
okay even if you slip up bro you get up
and try in you do not give up do you
understand me I'mma do it by myself
because I have no one to do it with
anyways my whole family doesn't do it
and I can't convince trying to convince
them for 10 years so no problem bro you
might be the reason your whole family
starts praying bro you might be the
reason so even if they're not doing it
bro you do it you do it okay
and bro bro I just I just hope that
happens you know I would dream about
that bro bro W let me tell you something
look I came to Islam 11 years ago do you
know how many of my family members are
praying Salah now my brother probably
all my brother not all of them my
brother I'm trying to get my cousins my
auntie even my mom I'm trying to Bro
Allah uses you as a tool in so guys what
you hearing now is brother just give the
reminder he tuned in he said he left
Islam um there was some questions that
he had we answer he came back to Islam
and we're going to teach him how to pray
Salah these are real life scenarios guys
when we talk about these things people
don't believe us this is a brother in
I'm going to teach myself he's a Muslim
again he's come back and Subhan Allah
we're going to teach him how to pray
Salah how to do W even memorize the
Quran we're going to get him into the
Quran program that we have been
launching brothers and sisters this is
where your donations are going I am
looking for in brother sister look we're
just 163 pounds away from our Target
we're looking for two people to give1
pounds in please a do you have any other
question for us bro can you message me
somewhere so I can contact you to help
you how to pray
Salah can you hear me yeah I'm talking
to I'm talking to you yeah how can I
contact you can you message the private
chat can I contact you have Instagram uh
yeah it's at um no no don't don't don't
mention that don't mention that message
me message me on my Instagram Ali da
hello yeah I'm I'm gonna send you guid
on I don't know if I have requests
on when you text i' I've messaged you
I've messaged you I don't think it's G
to show because I have
requests check your check your general
and check your request inshah you you'll
find me there
okay okay tell me look after yourself
bro is anything else I can help you
with what is it again problem email I've
messaged you we'll talk there
okay okay okay I'll send you my email
may Allah bless you bro don't ever
forget you are a Muslim and you love
Allah and his messenger okay don't don't
let anybody make you feel bad okay